Universal pipette tips are compatible
with universal pipetters they are made
with a medical grade polypropylene
material with a high Optical Clarity to
prevent sample contamination now you
would choose low retention to minimize
sample carryover for higher
reproducibility and you choose filter
tips if you would like to prevent sample
contamination into your pipettor now
this is a requirement if you're working
with molecular assays so keep that in
mind now you choose the size based on
the amount of analyte that is being used
as well as making sure it's compatible
with the pipettor make sure to choose
tips that fit the volume Mains of your
pipetting for example 1 to 20 2 to 50 20
to 200 200 to 1000 microliters Etc
something to keep in mind you also want
to choose a size where the volume that
you're pipetting is closer to the middle
of the range of your tip so for example
if you're pipetting 25 microliters you
would want to use a 50 microliter tip
more so than a 200 microliter tip
because 50 is closer to 25 than 200.
choose sterile tips to prevent sample
contamination and non-sterile tips when
contamination is not so much of a
concern